Привіт
друзі Сьогодні з вами в ефірі
європейська Солідарність і ми з вами
сьогодні знаходимося за адресою
Богомольця 10 тут знаходиться офіс
Міністерства внутрішніх справ чому люди
тут ми бачимо от збираються люди Чому
вони
тут вони тут бо разом з разом з нами з
усіма бо ми хочемо спонукати
правоохоронні органи
працювати якому швидше знайти того хто
днями звірячи побив нашого однопартійця
політв'язні патріота Володимира
[музика]
балуха дуже гучно
трішки розповім вам що саме
відбувається Нагадую що ми працюємо
наживо і працюватимо в такому режимі усю
акцію тож мерші підписуйтесь на наш
канал щоб бути в курсі що зараз відва
міні с України с Нані і наі
дав насі за долю України Стив насів і лю
на
[музика]
[оплески]
вороі побі
переможним ходу
ди сні не в ні бо краї бо плач не дав
нікому ще Свободи
хтоворець той зому має Сі полач нереба і
тому ще Свободи
доборею зновува сі Україну Україну я
давати герой давати герой сіди до серця
мого сіди до серця мого затво
ться
акція розкажу вам трохи про Володимира
[оплески]
[музика]
балухавав попросимо його
прокоментувати що саме який стан
Володимира палука та що зараз з ним
відбувається Доброго дня пане Ростиславе
Чи можете ви дати нам коментар чому ви
тут і що пройшли сказати
сьогодні дуже важливо розуміти що такі
злочини якя Володимира па який є полі
Кремля який нашим поротимом не
залишивться
відсунути відкладені вдоб шухляту забуті
прийшли сказати що цей злощн має бути
розслідуваний розслідуваний найчастіші
терміни повино знати правду не тільки
хто це зробив А І хто це замовив Дякую
вам давайте побачимо як збираються ось
бачимо Артура
[музика]
Герасимова народи гроїв наши славо для
нас зако наі
по українська є
держава на іяну по
свободна
українська є
державаі і
салу
[музика]
[оплески]
золоті
Луги дуть у мене кра і сумно
накри до поля до поля
похилася там старі
батьки
запла
стоять
прота а поки люди збираються я нагадаю
вам чому ми сьогодні зібралися тут на
вулиці Богомольця
зіщо вохороні о дали нам відповідьхто п
ру
[музика]
Володимира володимирмнин патріотя
Тіна який переслідувався і
переслідується тимчасовою оційною владою
[оплески]
[музика]
кримадух поколінь
за далеко
ілелеки повернуся
[музика]
нагадаю що пан Володимир балув після
початку окупації Криму демонстративно
відмовився від отримання російського
громадянства І сьогодні ми тут щоб
підтримати його і щоб поліція дала нам
відповідь хто побив підняв руку на
патріота України Володимира
[музика]
[оплески]
палусаі Володимира бака нині знає мабуть
кожен
українець він
кримчанин що постраждав за наш
українські
пра
Володимир грудня 201
по українй р на свої садині наголошую на
свої і коли окупаційна влада Крима
вимагала зняти Це цей прапор він
відмовився за
щодився
свободою з того часу для патріота
Володимира палуха почалися довгі місяці
слідств суддів
ремних застінок там він пізнав Шак
фізичних і психологічних
торту карателі зокрема змушували пана
Володимира відмовитися від українського
паспорту зрадити Україну і тоді вийти зі
в'язниці але незладний пан Володимир
вистояв віримо що вистоять він і зараз
коли бореться за своє здоров'я і
[музика]
життя і Усі хто зібрався сьогодні тут от
ви бачите вже доволі багато людей
зібралися під будівле мбс
ті хто молиться і вболіває за пана
Володимира по всій Україні за кордоном
де де нашого мужнього товариша теж
знають і поважають Сьогодні ми тут щоб
спитати у поліції хто підняв руку на
палуха адже ніхто не очікував що
витримавши тортури московських катів
Володимир потрапить у біду вдома у
Києві
коли 7 вересня 2019 року
стараннями птого президента України
Петра Порошенка пана Володимира балиха
було звільнено з в'язниці він одразу
почав сміливо відстоювати свою
громадянську позицію і підтримувати
європейську Солідарність і Петра
Порошенка Володимир відкрито
[музика]
заявлявщо безпеч тактика а мир потрібен
Україні не будьякою
ціною і ось проти ночі 8 вересня майже
на річницю визволення пана
балуха звірячі побили
невідомі Ми українці не можемо
залишитися байдужими до такого кричущого
злочину І сьогодні ми тут щоб спитати у
правоохоронців хто винен
А я Нагадую що ми працюємо наживо тож
якщо ви знаходитесь в Києві Чи чи і
просто не змогли приєтатись до акції або
знаходитись в іншому місті України або
світу ви можете спостерігати наживо Що
зараз відбувається тут біля
мбс А щоб не пропустити наші наступні
лайв-трансляції підпишіться на наш канал
ставте дзвіночок І ви будете в курсі
усіх
подій А я Нагадую що причини побиття
Володимира балуха наразі досі невідомі
Але у нашій команді Припускають що
причиною могла стати праукраїнська
позиція
Володимира на жаль зараз пан Володимир
балах знаходиться досі в тяжкому стані і
лікарі боряться за його життя
і ми сьогодні тут щоб сказати ми не дамо
зам'яти цю справу Ми хочемо
відповідей хто підняв руку на
палух ось ми бачимо вже зібралися
[музика]
люди куди ми Усі прийшли щоб Спитати хто
підняв руку на балуха ви знаєте коли
більше ніж рік тому ви говорили про те
проросійський Реванш насувається На
Україну багато людей сприймали це
давайте бути відвертими досить
несерйозно І що ми бачимо зараз бо
проросійський Реванш повернення і
розворот в сторону Росії це не тільки
відведення так званих а в реальності
відступ українських військ з землі за
поклали
життя Багато наших
воїнів це не
тільки тотальне зниження іміджа України
на міжнародній арені де Сьогодні на жаль
про Україну починають говорити без нас
часто напряму з країною агресором це не
тільки те що коїться всередині держави
починаючи від економіки і закінчуючи
боротьбою з коронавірусом коли
програються через з непрофесійність і
некомпетентність Влади майже всі позиції
і подивіться як котиться все вниз але це
також і те що боїться на вулицях це тиск
на активістів це побиття активістів це
підпали машини і те що сталося з
Володимиром палуком це не є просто
якийсь святовий випадок це дуже серйозна
подія тому що це теж елемент реваншу
якщо в нашій з вамі
країні активістив
волонтерів
ветеранів будуть бити і ці люди не
будуть знайдені не будуть покарані це є
теж елементом
реваншу тому Сьогодні ми з вами тут ми з
вами тут для того щоб привернути ще
більшу увагу до того що це не рядовий
випадок це один з елементів
ланцюжка
який чітко доводить що нашу з вами
велику країну намагаються знов повернути
в стояло країни агресора але ми цього не
допустимо європейська Солідарність
зробить
все для того щоб цього не сталося І те
що записано в нашій конституції а це є
курс на Європейський союз це є курс на
НАТО залишилося не на папері а
залишилося в реальних справах
української влади яку українська
опозиція на чолі з Європейської
солідарності буде жорстко до цього
спонукати а Володимиру балуку давайте
зараз побажаємо перш за все щоб
якнайскоріше він одужив і щоб все в
нього було добре І міцному йому зараз
здоров'я і будемо всі за нього молитися
сьогодні Дякую
вам Вітаю всіх же
така е
ситуація він в важкому стані і тому
те що трапилося Я хочу щоб всі зрозуміли
що той хто на цьому
спекулює деякі журналісти деякі там себе
називають громадським діячами
це це сорм тому що
балуха всі знають
Балух весь цей рік він як зв'язниці
вишов він ні одного дня не сидив
щоби з кимусь нені спілкуватись нені
зустрічатись не їздити по Україні
він він провів цей рік в
борбі тому коли кажуть що починають
збитавухи потім на намагаються сказати
щось якась там пян п'яна разборка що
якась якись потім сам упал потім
разбойное нападение це це
неппустимо тому що це
намагання нівелювати його нашу всю
боротьбу тому ми
тут
Я зовсім здивований
коли я сам особисто
предоставил
ряд як кажуть там підказок допомоги
поліції в тому щоб там з'ясовувати
обставини і потім чути що там от такій
версії це
ганьба я звертаюсь
до
поліції до руководства
Міністерства цей
хлопець Володимир він за Україну Там в
тюрме Він і за вас там боровся за
гідность нашої держави нашого
народу коли
го намагалися поставити на коліна я вам
це кажу тоді теж були
сумневи у деяких журналістав
що його там били
і вот я їх називаю мусорами в
в той каптёрке і він на коліна не встав
от це слідство ми будемо
в
відслежувати для того щоб дати
от відповііді не
тільки як це трапилось А на те що
останній рік в
нашій в нашій Україні це це явище от уже
закономерно Тобто ти коли борешся коли
ти відстоюєш оці символи цієї боротьби
намагаються якісь
мерзотники
десь
відслідкувати вбити побити а держава де
новая Влада вона робить вигляд що це
якась битовуха
це
неприпустимо ми це не дозволимо і вчора
і зараз я поїду на це місто і буду
спілкуватись з тою жінкою яка його
знайшла вона вчора такі слова казала Я
вас дуже прошу коли він прийде до тями
щоб ми зустрінули щоб я йому руку
пожала я такого патріота що не бачила і
і плакала в
телефон Я кажу що трапилось коли йму
намагалися укол
поставить і для цього треба було
разрезать вишиванку і вон от
будучи в такому стані він руку положили
іхо казав це дуже
дорога рубаха для
мене От от як як потім слухати от ці
цих
мерзотників ця
людина вона Я кожного разу казав що поки
він був там в тюрме коли запитували про
балха я казав я його кожного разу
називаю ширий
українець оце такий вот хлопець
і дуже я вірю в те що він тільки пройшов
і він обов'язково він
зобов'язан
видужити
Ми
багато зміст з України телефонують
і відслідковують що далі і
хочуть чимбудь допомогти я кажу Зараз ми
все робимо зараз немає такої по
потрібності але
є є дуже
велика потрібность для того
щоб цю справу ні
слілі і коли ми
[музика]
будемо бачити що це йде до цього ми
будемо всіх
закликати це наш
обов'язок
дякую
Шановні
колеги зараз народні депутати ми тоді
йдемо до керівництва Міністерства до
керівництва поліції для того щоб дуже
серйозно поговорити про цю справу тому
що Зрозуміло ніяка це не товуха ніяке це
не випадкове явище тому що за останній
рік кількість нападів на активістів
кількість тиску і нападів на
проукраїнські налаштованих українців на
патріотів на волонтерів на ветеранів
вона дійсно зашкалює і
сьогодні жодним чином ми не можемо
допустити щоб це продовжувалося і тим
більше підвищлося Дякую вам за увагу і
чекайте на нас
[оплески]
дякую
[музика]
шановні
друзі Володимир Балух - це та людина на
яких тримається Україна Володимир Балух
- це людина яка в Криму у найважчіх часи
залишала за собою український паспорт
вивішували над своїм будинком наш
національний прапор навіть тоді коли до
нього приходили фесбешники навіть тоді
коли на нього тиснули усіма можливими
засобами російський режим але він завжди
казав що він залишається і буде
українцем і над його будинком завжди
висівсяні жовтий прапор до тих пір поки
такі люди будуть залишатися без захисту
України ми не матимемо справедливої
чесної країни ми сприймаємо напад на
Володимира балуха не просто як напад на
громадянина А як напад на наші цінності
на наші Свободи на символи боротьби за
нашу незалежність і суверенітет країни і
тому сьогодні тут партія європейська
Солідарність прийшла аби спитати у
міністра внутрішніх справ Авакова
наскільки Серйозно він ставиться до цієї
Справи ми вважаємо що ця справа має бути
на особливому
контролі влади ми вважаємо що саме таких
громадян має захищати в першу чергу
Україна тому що якщо Україна не може
захистити власні цінності власних
громадян які борться за свободу То як
вона може захистити потімю ю країну тому
сьогодні тут наші депутати Зараз Пішли
на прийом до авахова аби вимагати у
нього взяти цю справу на особливий
контроль Ми і надалі будемо тримати цю
справу на контролі бо переконані що
захищаючи балуха ми захищаємо всю
Україну тому що він захищав Україну
навіть тоді коли це було для багатьох
громадян виявлялось абсолютно
неможливим ми знаємо що тут однодумці
які з нами хочуть щоб Україна була
незалежною але Україна буде тоді
незалежною Коли нам буде небайдуже доля
кожного патріота і саме тому ми тут і Я
впевнений що ми зробимо так щоб ми знали
і ті хто напав на балуха і ті хто його
замовив А головне Чому вони на нього
замовили саме зараз коли здійснюється
тиск на наших активістів на наших
громадських діячів на
волонтерів Я впевнений що скільки тут
людей прийшло скільки нас людей
небайдужих прийшло це знак того що ми
обов'язково переможемо балох воював за
нас там в окупованому Криму ми зараз
обов'язково захистимоймо тут у вільній
Україні Слава Україні Героям
[оплески]
Слава будь ласка ще
ві Вітаю Мене звати Сергій європейська
Солідарність Печерський район для мене
як для молодої людини пан Володимир є
прикладом патріотизму та прикладом для
наслідування коли йнинни я особливо був
неймовірно щасливим тому що він дійсно є
прикладом для наслідування те що зараз
відбувається в мене серце просто
розривається через всеце цинічні сотні
покитьки які просто побили нашого
патріота нашого побратима Я вважаю що ми
патріотична частина суспільство не
можемо дозволити щоб ця справа була
зам'ята Ми маємо довести цю справу до
суду винні мають бути покарані понести
справедливе і найжорсткіше покарання
тому що якщо Влада не покарає цих винних
Я думаю українське суспільство покаже що
тюрма для цих покиків буде найкращим
варіантом Слава Україні
Слава друзі залишаємося поки тут чекаємо
наших депутатів почуємо від них яка була
відповідь авахова Ну і звичайно ми
залишаємо цю справу поза увагою до тих
пір поки справа не буде передана до суду
і суд винесе сподіваємося і віримо в це
справедливий
[музика]
вирок
А я Нагадую що ми знаходимося на вулиці
Богомольця 10 де депутати європейської
солідарності шли до Авакова щоб задати
йому одне питання Хто замовив табив
Володимира балуха нашого побратима і
[музика]
патріота ми працюємо наживо підписуйтесь
на наш канал щобти першими що тут
відбувається
[музика]
олотілу ведуть у небо край і сумно над
крули до поля до поля
похилилася там старі
батьки
запла
стоять
прошти було
[музика]
їм для тих хто щойно приєднався Нагадую
що ми тут зібралися щоб спонукати
правоохоронні органи працювати і якомога
швидше знайти того хто днями звірячи
побив нашого однопартійця нашого
попратима Володимира чекають тебе сила
уропаже чекає тамйго
душа за
пішов
задуто людейіли Т щоб задати питання То
підняв
[музика]
налу
Нагадую що однієї з
версій причин нападу на Володимира
палука є його проукраїнська
позиція так так
чи ні Пішли наші депутати питати
[музика]
у нагадую щоми
заразчекахі МС свічка
нега до Віку буде
вже
горіти горітиме вона молодий
[музика]
юнак Добрий день пане Сергію Tube
європейської солідарності Скажіть будь
ласка є якісь оновлення щодо стану пана
Володимира
балуха німаці Ми не маємо жодних новин
але Ми впевнені
що той дух який
то ви звичайно йому буде приємно
дізнатися коли він буде вже спримати
нормально інформацію тут багато людей
підтриму що вони хочу справедливості що
вони хочу тої Вій України за якою він
боровся в крияму і бореться тут досі неі
перебуває на лікарняному р дякуємо
вам ось ми бачимо скільки людей
зібралися щоб Спитати
хто напав на Володимира палуха і
вимагати справедливого розслідування
цієї справи Бо це не просто бита вуха як
намагаються це подати
це жахливий великий злочин який потребує
негайного
розслідування не
було Не
буложе
ми тут бачимо голову солідарної молоді
дінару хабібулаєву розкажіть пані дінаро
для Ютубу європейської солідарності чому
ви тут і які що ви хочете сказати
сьогодні Головне що справа балука і його
жорстке побиття - це підняття руху на
українську взагалі незалежність тому що
балк є сиволом української незалежності
він точно знає що таке
кремлівський тоталітаризм він точно знає
що таке кремлівські тюрми і він точно
знає що таке країнаагресор і сьогодні
коли відбувається така справа коли не
розслідуються Напевно чи розслідуються
ми не знаємо тому громадськість прийшла
Просто показати що вона тримається на
особистому контролі і вимагає прадливого
рахливого розслідування справи І все
тому у нас питання хто підняв руку на
палуха чи є тут політич мотивчи Немає
його і нам хотілось би дізнатися правду
І тому ми прийшли аби показати що
громадськість це тримає на контролю аби
це не злили цю справу не закрили швидко
не показали якогось там новинного
новинну людину да тобто більш детальніше
більш глибше розслідували справи тому
Для нас це є зараз основним будемо
тримати це на контролі і у разі якщо
МС вирішить це замяти в нас є такий
громадський інструмент як мінімум от
тому будемо проходити тому що для нас
Володимир балу це дуже
вахома персона для українського
суспільства Тим паче він зараз мав плани
балотуватися в Київську область в Раду
чи є тут політичний моти невідомо тому
хотілось би аби суспільство знало правду
Дякуємо вам
а для тих хто щойно приєднався до нас
нагадую ми зібралися сьогодні тут для
того щоб вимагати справедливого
розслідування побиття нашого побратима
Володимира
[музика]
валуха
Ми чекаємо на повернення наших
[музика]
депутатівчу
Нагадую що ми чекаємо тут біля МВС
повернення наших депутатів європейської
солідарності Що пішли до пана
Авакова вимагати справедливого
розслідування справи Володимира
балуха
який на якого
напали тут у Мирному
[музика]
Києві друзі а поки ми чекаємо повернення
наших депутатів ді МВС хочемо нагадати
що вчора Україна отримала ще одну дуже і
дуже тривожну новину представники так
званих ДНР та ЛНР за згодою офісу
президента мають наміри інспектувати
позиції збройних сил України що ви
думаєте з приводу цих
ініціатив пишіть нам у
коментарі А
ми А ми спитаємо поки У пані
дінари пані дінари ви звісно чули про те
що представники ДНР та ЛНР будуть нібито
будуть ктувати наші позиції як що ви
думаєте з цього приводу насправді от
ситуація повністю з тим як зараз
теперішня Влада регулює
лавка ситуацію на Донбасі вона не те що
слабка вона капітулянтська вона точно
показує що Зеленський чітко Іро викону
план Кремля і починаючи з його
призначень починаючи з того
які вислови які заяви робить
кін які заяви роблять представники ткг
чітко показує те що насупають і мені
здається тут треба так
само мати жорстку позицію з боку
громадськості аби не дозволяти все ж
таки владі розпускати рухи і розпускати
по суті все те що тримали це на
територію тому що це недопустимо і мені
здається що далі буде ще гірше
якщо Зеленський не зупиниться то ми дуже
швидко побачимо як ми капітулювали і
тому тут ситуація в тому що навіть
міжнародні партнери нам не зможуть
допомогти в то в тому разі якщо сам
Зеленський представник нашої країни по
суті Гарант нашої
держави
головнокомандувач в кінці кінців не може
захистити свої території і не може
жорстко дати подубам тим
хто нашу територію загар загарбив А це
Росії агресор Він навіть не може
висловити це цей вираз Мені здається це
є проблемою тому який
стиль Який сенс вкладає В розвиток події
зеле коли він вийшов з тюрми він
розказував як його підтримували ваші
листи і ваші словап зараз вони йому
необхідні
теж А ми поки чекаємо повернення наших
депутатів від міністра
Авакова вони пішли до наші депутати
пішли до МВС щоб зустрітися з
аваковим
[музика]
славу бачимо якісь
люди входять у будівлю але це не наші
депутати вони ще не
[музика]
повертаються
стане ті сроні мої попаркують у
[музика]
сині
щощо
[музика]
буде
йкра
думає ще одна наша депутатка Ірина ф Іна
фрис пише офіс Зеленського продовжує
політику зради національних інтересів
нашої держави каже пані фріс
запровадження спільного інспектування в
рамках ткг свідчить про те що Зеленський
разом зі своїми злочинним оточенням
здійснює дії я що мають ознаки державної
зради облаштування позиції збройних сил
України особливо у районах бойового
зіткнення з ворогом є інформацією що
відноситься до державної таємниці
залучення до інспектування представників
ордло які не мають Та не можуть мати
доступу та допуску до державної таємниці
є
злочином він передбачений частиною
третьою статті 111 надання іноземній
державі іноземній організації або їх
представникам допомоги у проведенні
підривної діяльності проти
України
пишіть друзі Чи згодні ви з думкою Ірини
фріс чи є державна зрада у рішенні
спільного інспектування
позицій
[музика]
пишете у коментарях
я нічого не ю
як я тобі
[музика]
казала
щолотілу
ведуть
небока і сумро
на до поля до поля
боласа там старі
батьки
заплакать
сять
простати було
ї силя а він героєм яв
[музика]
Мона молодий
коза Та біля добові калина росте на мені
очі чекають тебе сила у розпачі плаче
сина все чекає Там Бога вже його душама
Я голю за голю пішов на жі за брату і
долю нових поколінь затитко у мові
далеко і крилами лелекині повернуться
[музика]
[оплески]
Доброго дня от я бачу у вас дуже
красномовний плакат А скажіть будь ласка
чи не вважаєте ви що побиття
проукраїнських активістів це ознака
проросійського
реваншутіли В ніч до коза бачиш Сину мій
свічка не
згаса до Віку буде
вже
горіти горітиме вона молодий
юнак молодий
козак там
міятоповіками росте мамені очі чекають
тебе
сироро чить лаче синаже чекає Там полаже
його душа я волю за волю пішов ладачі за
правду і долю нових поколінь за тих хто
у морі
[музика]
далеко не тільки ті хто зараз зібрався
тут підтримує Володимира балуха його
підтримує Вся Україна і не тільки
Україна Я думаю за за її межами Теж
добре знають нашого патріота і нашого
політв'язня який зараз саме бореться за
життя в одній із лікарень Києва тож
хочемо
поділитися
точ точкою зору політичного експерта
який
вчора виступав в ефірі
са ля
нагадаємо рівно рік тому 7
вересня Ну не рівно рік тому цими днями
у 2019 році в Україну в в рамках обміну
повернулося 35 осіб серед яких 24
полонені моряки та політв'язні Сенцов
польченка балукс сущенко Карпюк клих
гриб Євген та Артур панови бекіров та
сизонович на місцевих виборах 2020
Володимир Балух приєднався до команди
птого президента Петра Порошенка та
європейської
солідарност два довгих роки провів па
Володимир у кремлівських застінках
серпня 2017 року окупанти засудили
кримчанина балуха до трьох років семи
місяців у колонії поселенні і штрафу у
10 000 рублів звинувативши його у нібито
незаконному зберіганні
боєприпасів насправді балох просто
вивісив прапор України над своїм
[музика]
будинком це сталося у Криму у грудні
2013 року ВС чекають
тебе з тих пір для пана
балоха почався почалося слідство суди та
тюремні стіни а 5 липня 2018 року
підконтрольний окупантом суд визнав
палуха винним ще й у побитті начальника
ізолятора тимчасового утримання і
засудив до пти років позбавлення волі і
штрафу 10 000 лі хоча відомо що саме
начальник СІЗО штовхнув паука і він
був і вона його
[музика]
недоказана друзі ось до мікрофону
підходить Сергій
Таран послухаємо
[музика]
його шановні друзі зараз народні
депутати від європейської солідарності
будуть виходити з цього будинку Вони
мають нову інформацію по справі а поки
ми їх чекаємо ми додаємо слово дінарі
габібулаєві Молодіжці європейкої
солідарності
Доброго дня всім а насправді Я дуже
дякую що прийшли сьогодні сюди справжні
громадяни тому що вони точно знають що в
теперішній ситуації коли зелена Влада по
всіх фронтах здає нашу територію дуже
важливо все ж таки відстояти своїх
відстояти тих хто став символом
української незалежності в тому числі
Володимира балоха чому я кажу відстояти
тому що те що відбулося з ним а це
жорстке побиття яке залишає дуже багато
питань чи є політичні мотиви в цьому
невідомо чому ми сюди прийшли сюди
прийшли молоді активні люди для того щоб
сказати що вони тримають це на своєму
контролі як нас навчив До речі наш
президент Ми хотіли би Показати що ми не
дамо поліції ми не дамо правоохоронним
органам і не дамо
владі якось замовчати Це або залишити
без дуже детального розгляду ми
вимагаємо справедливого розслідування ми
вимагаємо аби були покарані злочинці і
ті хто замовляв можливо балуха для нас
дуже важливо все ж таки звернутися зараз
до правоохоронних органів показати
свою своє відчуття справедливості і своє
відчуття громадського обов'язку прийти і
підтримати Володимира тому що зараз він
дійсно знаходиться в дуже важкому стані
в лікарні і хотілось би аби поліція
розслідувала детальніше і скрупульозніше
те що відбулося в ту ніч АА і тому у нас
є одне питання хто підняв руку на балуха
хто підняв руку на палуха хто підняв
руку на палуха хто підняв руку на палуха
хто підняв руку на балуха хто підняв
руку на балуха хто підняв руку на балуха
руку на
балуха шановні однодумці шановні
українці близько години тривала зустріч
керівництва МВС і національної поліції з
народними депутатами європейської
солідарності перше справа знаходиться на
особистому контролю міністра МВС а
також заступника міністра МВС Антона
геращенка та керівника поліції Андрія
Крищенка але
ми зосередили увагу керівництва мбс та
керівництва національної поліції на тому
що
прозорість життя і діяльності Володимира
балуха після
звільнення зосереджує нас як народних
депутатів на
думці що цей напад
це замах на
вбивство цього активіста цього
політв'язня з боку країни
агресо також обіцяю
що європейська
Солідарність народні депутати і всі
небайдужі будуть постійно тримати
розслідування цієї справи на жорсткому
контролі
[оплески]
дякую
друзі Ми сьогодні зараз ідемо але Ми
тримаємо на контролі все те що буде
відбуватися в цьому будинку справа балга
- це атака на наші цінності а наші
цінності ми нікому не здамо Слава
[оплески]
Україні